1995 hat nintendo den virtual boy
veröffentlicht es war die erste
portabler kommerziell erhältliche via
brille und ein riesen flop
vor allem weil die brille wohl super
ungemütlich war und kaum farben anzeigen
konnte mittlerweile haben sich aus dem
rot-schwarzen mario tennis das visual
voice komplett hochauflösend geänderte
3d welten entwickelt heutige spiele wie
barfly felix haben eine mega
beeindruckende interaktive umgebung
unglaublich realistische physik und eine
nie zuvor dagewesene immersion seit dem
virtual boy sind inzwischen 25 jahre
vergangen und virtual reality hat
riesige fortschritte gemacht
deswegen haben wir uns die frage
gestellt wie wird wie er denn noch mal
25 jahren aussehen werden wir wie auch
spiele gar nicht mehr von der echten
welt unterscheiden können können wir
spielen vielleicht mit unserem gehirn
steuern oder tauchen wir vielleicht
sogar komplett in die virtuelle welt ein
genau darum geht es heute sagte watson
[Musik]
in christchurch
für viele ist der heilige gral der
virtuellen realität fulda fwr das ist
ein begriff aus dem anime sportart
online und beschreibt eine virtuelle
realität die sich nicht nur auf sensoren
oder headsets beschränkt sondern alle
sinneswahrnehmungen umfasst ihr spürt
schmeckt riecht und hört eine alles
umfassende virtuelle realität anders
also als bei ready player an wo man ja
immer noch sein körper hat und den in
der echten welt bewegt um das spiel zu
steuern
und tatsächlich ist die forschung gar
nicht mehr so weit davon entfernt wie
ihr vielleicht denkt um fulda umzusetzen
brauchen wir zwei wichtige
technologische errungenschaften
zum einen muss du damit du dich in der
virtuellen realität bewegen kannst eine
direkte verbindung von einem gehirn zu
einem computer haben das kind jetzt
erstmal abenteuerlich ist aber möglich
und zwar durch brain machine interfaces
eine schnittstelle zwischen dir und
einem computer die es dem computer
ermöglicht deine gedanken zu lesen mit
einem brain machine interface können wir
also ein gerät oder eben ein spiel
alleine mit hilfe von unseren gedanken
steuern an solchen schnittstellen
arbeiten wissenschaftler schon eine
ganze weile 2013 ist es forschern der
harvard university gelungen mit hilfe
der gedanken eines wissenschaftlers den
schwanz einer lebenden ratte zu bewegen
dafür haben die forscher einen achtung
elektroenzephalogramm gehirn zu gehirn
interface verwendet so bezeichnet man
eine künstliche verbindung von zwei
gehirnen in diesem fall zwischen
wissenschaftlern und ratte der computer
konnte damit die hirnaktivitäten des
forschers interpretieren und an die
ratte weiterleiten
das ist jetzt aber noch keine direkte
gedankenübertragung vielmehr wird hier
ein bestimmtes signal muster erkannt und
als schalter benutzt um eine stimulation
auszulösen
einen schritt näher an echter
gedankenübertragung ist ein brain brain
interface versucht zwischen affen an der
duke university
hier wurde ein komplexes gehirn signal
in ein eindimensionales signal übersetzt
bevor es übertragen wurde
damit war es mehreren affen möglich ihre
gemeinsamen gehirnaktivitäten
miteinander zu verschmelzen
so konnte ein netzwerk aus gehirnen
einen virtuellen arm dreidimensional
bewegen um ein ziel zu erreichen
das ist schon ziemlich cool aber wäre
wahrscheinlich als computerspiel
ziemlich langweilig und wahrscheinlich
sehr eintönig trotzdem sind diese
technologien
wegweisend für full life jahr denn
erstens demonstrieren sie dass ein
computer in der lage ist menschliche
gedanken in signale umzuwandeln
und zweitens dass es sogar möglich ist
mehrere gehirne zu einem netzwerk
zusammen zu schließen
zwei jahre später ist es
wissenschaftlern der university of
california gelungen mit vergleichbarer
technologie einem querschnittsgelähmten
mann zu helfen das erste mal nach fünf
jahren wieder zu laufen
hierfür wurden elektroden auf den kopf
und an den beinen des mannes befestigt
ein computer hat dann seine neuronalen
signale aus gewesen darauf gewartet weil
er daran dachte zu laufen und dann
selbst elektrische signale generiert die
die muskeln angesteuert haben das
unglaubliche daran ist dass so die
rückenmarksverletzung des mannes einfach
umgangen werden konnte diese experimente
sind schon eine weile her und natürlich
noch lange nicht das was uns fulda
einmal verspricht aber überlegt mal
innerhalb von zwei jahren haben wir
gesehen wie gedanken erst nur einen
rattenschwanz und dann die beine eines
mannes kontrollieren konnten
und mittlerweile ist schon viel mehr
möglich dazu kommen wir aber gleich
ok eine direkte verbindung zwischen
gehirn und computer herzustellen ist
also möglich
doch bedingungen nummer zwei ist für
eine fulda vielleicht noch wichtiger
um komplett in eine virtuelle realität
abtauchen zu können müssen computer
nicht nur in der lage sein die gedanken
des users auszulesen sondern auch
sinneserfahrungen direkt in das zentrale
nervensystem hinein zu senden die
kommunikation zwischen gehirn und
computer soll keine einbahnstraße sein
und genau hier muss ich euch leider
enttäuschen davon sind wir doch ziemlich
weit entfernt
hier muss die wissenschaft noch
herausfinden was genau
sinneswahrnehmungen überhaupt ausmachen
wir müssen also noch einiges mehr
darüber verstehen wie unser gehirn
funktioniert bevor wir selber
synthetische sinneswahrnehmungen
produzieren können das ist auch bei den
motorischen signalen noch nicht ganz
klar dass die prothese bei dem gelernten
man funktioniert hat bedeutet nicht dass
die forscher die neuronalen code
geknackt haben
vielmehr interpretiert die maschine nur
ein sehr großes signal von dem die
wissenschaftler noch nicht einmal wissen
wo es genau herkommt ok gehen wir mal
davon aus wir knacken die neuronalen
code in den nächsten 25 jahren und ich
verstehe den computer genauso gut wie er
mich versteht dann steht einer fuldaer
fia auf zumindest technologisch nichts
mehr im weg du kommst also nach einem
anstrengenden tag nach hause setzt sich
auf die couch und staat ist die
simulation ab jetzt spielen sich
erfahrungen ausschließlich in deinem
gehirn ab rein theoretisch tun sie das
jetzt schon aber auch alle
sinneseindrücke kommen jetzt quasi in
deinem gehirn direkt an und nicht mehr
durch die zensoren bewegungen in der
echten welt sind gar nicht mehr nötig
wenn du daran denkst einen daumen nach
oben zu geben dann wird das signal vom
computer abgefangen und du fühlst die
bewegung nur virtuell aus dann echter
körper bewegt sich gar nicht schreibt
man dieses konzept auf die spitze dann
würde das bedeuten dass du nur noch
siehst schmeckst fühlst und liest was
die der computer übermittelt
und das ist ja schon irgendwie ein
ziemlich gruseliger gedanke oder bis wir
fuldaer umsetzen können wird noch einige
zeit vergehen
schließlich brauchen wir nicht nur die
technologie damit sich computer und
mensch gegenseitig verstehen sondern
auch unfassbar leistungsfähige computer
die realistische umgebungen rändern und
sogar sinneswahrnehmungen produzieren
können
wir wissen noch gar nicht welche
rechenleistung hierfür nötig sein wird
eine weitere möglichkeit wäre es
übrigens dass wir es dem gehirn
überlassen detaillierte erfahrungen
selbst zu generieren
also quasi luzide träumen mit
stützrädern wenn man so will
die hirnforschung um die hierfür
benötigten höheren hirngebiete
anzusteuern ist aber auch sehr aufwendig
trotzdem gibt es natürlich spannende
entwicklungen die zumindest andeuten
wohin die reise geht wie 2009 10 hat das
us unternehmen bereits angekündigt seine
hightech spielhallen auch nach
deutschland zu bringen
bisher kann man an standorten wie zum
beispiel in london dubai oder new york
schon mixed reality ausprobieren
dort werdet ihr mit einem via headset
speziellen noise cancelling kopfhörern
haptischen handschuhen und 22 ganzkörper
sensoren ausgestattet das ist dann ein
bisschen so wie bei ray player und mit
hilfe dieser ganzen hardware
katapultiert euch dann bereut direkt in
ein level im star wars universum jagd
geister mit den ghostbusters oder erlebt
abenteuer im marvel cinematic universe
diese ganze hardware könnte aber auch
schon bald überflüssig werden
2017 hat das entwicklerstudio in europe
das wii-spiel waiting vorgestellt in dem
spiel seid ihr ein kind mit
telekinetischen kräften gefangen in
einem regierungs labor auf dem weg aus
ihrem gefängnis kämpft ihr euch mit
telekinetischen kräften an roboter waren
vorbei ach ja und irgendwas hab ich noch
vergessen genau ihr steuert das spiel
mit euren gedanken es klingt unglaublich
aber fokussiert eure gedanken auf ein
objekt das sie mit telekinese zur waffe
machen wollt dann erkennt ein via
headset das gebäude und waking sind
wahnsinnig cool aber immer noch kein
full life be a
hier nutzen hersteller und entwickler
noch hardware und sensoren die zwar für
immer mehr in version sorgen aber noch
nicht an eine echte erfahrung
herankommen in einer echten fulda ist
wie arag könnt ihr aber nicht nur
videospielen nachgehen
viele hobbys die in der echten welt mit
großer gefahr und teuren anschaffungen
verbunden sind wie zb motorradfahren
fallschirmspringen oder gerätetauchen
können einfach virtuell stattfinden
bei echter full life jahr ist die
erfahrung gehabt theoretisch nicht von
der realität zu unterscheiden
so könnte man auch traumata patienten
helfen sich ihren ängsten in einer
kontrollierten umgebung zu stellen oder
stellt euch mal vor ein angehender
chirurg könnte seine ersten operationen
komplett virtuell durchführen
vorausgesetzt so etwas wie masse memory
überträgt sich von der wm
echte welt aber das spricht eigentlich
nichts gegen das gehirn die ganze zeit
denkt dass die bewegungen wirklich
ausgeführt werden
übrigens wie chirurgen heute schon
virtuell arbeiten das zeigen wir euch in
einem der nächsten videos hier auf
doktor watson abonniert gerne den kanal
um das nicht zu verpassen wir laden jede
woche ein neues video hoch ok bei dem
ganzen optimismus dürfen wir aber nicht
vergessen dass wir uns auch gründlich
gedanken über die philosophischen
gesundheitlichen und psychologischen
fragen machen sollten
es ist zum beispiel super wichtig dass
wir uns fragen was passiert wenn wir
maschinen wortwörtlich unsere gedanken
kontrollieren lassen
ich meine stellt euch mal vor pop-ups
würden direkt an euer gehirn gesendet
werden
und was passiert wenn ihr euch stunden
lang vielleicht sogar tagelang in einer
virtuellen realität auf haltet da kommt
ja einiges an daten zusammen schon heute
sind allein eure kontaktdaten und
nachrichten eine wertvolle währung für
viele konzerne
schaut euch dazu auch gerne unser video
darüber an was whatsapp und co wirklich
über euch und eure freunde wissen was
aber wenn dank fulda fdi art komplette
psychologische profile von euch zu
werbezwecken weiterverkauft werden
mit euren intimsten gedanken und
persönlichsten gefühlen
obwohl ich also vielleicht niemandem
davon erzähle was war ein riesiger irene
fischer fan ich bin spült der
algorithmus mir alle möglichen
merchandise und konzerttickets in meine
social media feeds dabei hätte ich das
vielleicht lieber niemandem erzählt und
das für mich behalten und im vergleich
zu direkter gedanken und emotionen
kontrolle sind pop ups im gehirn noch
gar nichts kein digitales system ist
unverwundbar
stell dir mal vor hackern wurde es
gelingen zugriff auf den computer zu
bekommen der meine fia simuliert so
könnte man mir ganz einfach den gedanken
einpflanzen dass ich meine kontodaten an
irgendjemanden weiterleite oder man sagt
dafür dass sich helene fischer nicht
mehr mag dafür braucht man nur das
schmerzzentrum im gehirn zu stimulieren
während ich atemlos höhere außerdem
bleibt natürlich auch die sorge was
passiert wenn eine virtuelle umgebung so
realistisch und msi wird dass sie die
realität nach und nach fad und
langweilig erscheinen lässt in der
echten welt kostet alles geld ist
anstrengend und ich kann mich verletzen
in der virtuellen welt kann nicht
fliegen die welt retten und das weltall
erkunden
macht es einen unterschied wenn ich weiß
dass das alles nicht echt ist vielleicht
aber ich weiß auch dass computerspiele
nicht echt sind und sie machen mir
trotzdem spaß
vielleicht sind wir irgendwann alle wie
bei matrix an maschinen angeschlossen
das könnte schwerwiegende psychische
folgen für uns haben bis hin zum
kompletten verlust von identität und
körpergefühl
das sind alles fragen die unbedingt
adressiert werden müssen und ganz
nebenbei um mal komplett das thema zu
wechseln ist das eine mögliche erklärung
für das fermi paradoxon intelligentes
leben im universum existiert aber alle
kulturen haben erkannt dass es mehr spaß
macht sein leben in der simulation zu
verbringen als im echten langweiligen
weltall zu fliegen
optimistisch über die zukunft von ba zu
sein ist aber erstmal gar nicht so
verkehrt denn immerhin gibt es auch
jeden anders dazu wenn man sich mal
anschaut welchen technologischen
fortschritt erst allein in letzten zehn
jahren gab ist das gar nicht so
unrealistisch dass wir in den nächsten
25 jahren zumindest einen prototypen
einer full life jahre sehen können early
adopter würde ich aber wahrscheinlich
trotzdem nicht werden wollen
dieses video wurde unterstützt von
audible ich möchte euch heute eines
meiner lieblingsbücher vorstellen
nämlich ray player one habe ich ja schon
mehrfach jetzt im video erwähnt das ist
eine geschichte über einen jungen in
einer dystopischen zukunft der fast
alles in einer virtuellen realität macht
und diese virtuelle realität die oasis
die wurde von einem menschen erschaffen
jetzt gestorben ist und wer hat da ganz
viele easteregg versteckt und wenn man
alle findet dann erbt man die oasis und
diese geschichte wurde jetzt letztens
verfilmt von steven spielberg und
vielleicht kennen wahrscheinlich mehr
leute den film als das buch aber wie so
oft das muss ich einfach immer wieder
sagen ist das buch besser als der film
und ihr könnt euch das jetzt auch
kostenlos runterladen 30 tage kostenlos
testen bei audible wenn ihr den link
unten in der video beschreibung
verwendet und damit unterstütze und auch
uns und unseren kanal
vielen dank dafür jetzt interessiert
mich aber auf jeden fall eure meinung
glaubt ihr eine full life jahr wäre eine
gute idee oder würden wir dann wie bei
sword online für immer darin gefangen
sein welche gewinne und welche gefahren
sie dir dabei diskutiert gerne mit mir
unten in den kommentaren ansonsten wie
immer bleibt neugierig bis dahin strickt